Good morning, sal y Jaramillo greets you with
your briefing today, Monday, February 8,
a new report shows that the
value of houses in the Las Vegas Valley
remains above average, but
also warns that this could be a mirage for
the real estate industry.  reports
that the average sale in January of a
family home registered at 345 thousand
dollars, this figure in pairs with the
averages that broke records in
November and December and also reflects
an increase of more than 13 percent more
than in January 2020 and before  of
closings due to the pandemic and the values ​​of
apartments and condominiums have also
increased and registered sales at an
average of 193 thousand dollars per unit
the report added that the increase in
home values ​​is due to the fact that fewer
people are selling their houses and to
the  Sometimes there are few houses for sale in the
valley at the moment
the buccaneers are the new champions
of the nfl after defeating the kansas city chips 31 to 9 in the
In the game rhythm they
would be during the superbowl and thus
becoming the only team to be
crowned at home in addition to liquidating
the kansas city chiefs and the
buccaneers managed to obtain their second
title in their history this time with the
help of their quarterback tom  brady
who earned his seventh nfl ring
more than anyone else
and it was another great weekend for
home team the golden knights who
now top their division by beating
the los angeles kings on sunday
despite the kings falling  They started off on
the right foot scoring the first two
goals the golden knights
reestablished themselves winning 4-3
the team heads to anaheim but not
before several games against the
bucks starting tuesday
yesterday's game was the second the goldens have played
eyes this after having
to postpone several games for 10 days
due to the pandemic
and the super news that was revealed during
the superbowl on Sunday was undoubtedly the
former ju  star gador of the golden
knights seri will be part of the team of
reporters and analysts of channel 8 reports, it
is anticipated that he will provide a
unique perspective to the coverage of the
national hockey league as well as that
of the golden knights gerard who begins
their collaboration  with our
sports teams starting today Monday during
our news slots at 6 in
the afternoon on your channel 8 now we are going
with the weather forecast,
a day with sun and clouds and
temperatures above normal will be expected
Close to 70 degrees tomorrow
more clouds are approaching have a good day
I am I came out Jaramillo and this was great
in Spanish
[Music]